i'd like to come back to the 100 hours a
week when you were working 100 hours a
week you
you continue to work very hard
and that is
i think certainly a defining
characteristic but even more so for me
it seems like one of your defining
characteristics is the ability to focus
and prioritize focusing
and you mentioned earlier that a lot of
the
most creative people in the world
schedule their creativity i mean this is
true across the board right whether it's
jerry seinfeld or certain musicians i've
spoken with
the most consistently creative people
have rules and structures and
constraints so it seems like you've done
something very much the same to
box out time to focus and i just want to
perhaps give an example of what your
schedule might look like and i want you
to correct this if it's changed but this
is from the observer effect and
the question was about the schedule in
the morning and here's how it goes i'll
just read a few lines
quote so this will sound incredibly lazy
compared to some leaders i wake up at
around 6 30 in the morning and spend
some time with my kids and wife at 7 30
i go work out at 8 30 i go for a walk
even in winter i found this is often
where i do my best thinking at 9 30 i
read for 30 minutes to an hour sometimes
i read the news but you'll also find an
ever-rotating stack of books in my
office next to my bed on tables around
the house books on history leadership
biographies it's pretty eclectic mix
much like my taste of music finally my
quote unquote work day really starts at
10 30. does your schedule still look
pretty similar to this or has it changed
uh no it's pretty similar actually today
i started at 11 a.m was my first kind of
thing
so i ended up getting 30 minutes longer
than i anticipated but but uh yeah i
mean this is pretty much my everyday
life and i think paul graham of y
combinator fame um said a few years ago
he penned this paper that was
kind of an aha moment for me about a
meeting um schedule or maker schedule
yeah how different they are
and it was like something kind of
resonated deeply with me and i think a
lot of people think they have to be in
the meeting schedule all the time and
that that is what's required to be an
effective leader
where in reality
i think you can kind of be an effective
leader no matter what your style is
but it has to be true to you so that you
can unlock your own sort of superpowers
and in general i would say most people
don't stop enough and think hard enough
about their priorities and focusing on
the problems that is the most worthwhile
for them to try to solve and they more
operate on a kind of first come first
served basis when it comes to their time
so it pretty much is the way my current
schedule works too and i often don't
take more than three or maybe four
things that i do
on each and every day
and i try to be very very sort of tough
on
saying no which isn't always the most
fun thing to do i will say
but it also means as a factor that i
tend to
get more stuff done of the things that
truly matter in a given day and more
time to think about other things as well
than perhaps a normal kind of ceo in a
normal kind of nine to five or nine two
seven gig whatever they end up doing
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
you